tell us about this tell us about
wanderlust us a this is an audio book
that you have coming out and what is
what happens on this because you can't
really tell from from the cover that's
not obvious no it's not oh okay yeah
this is a delicious audio gift for your
brains in ear holes Conan and I love to
travel so very much ss to you you know
we've been everywhere together to belly
no yeah well yeah we have we've traveled
together yes yes I would tell everyone
about what we did but you made me sign
the NDA yes yes do you still have I
think you're fascinated with American
history you love American history oh and
this is you're exploring it and and sort
of telling us what the German influences
and American history a little bit yes
yes so you are a good close yes close
but no cigarette II you may have to
leave soon I'm a Conan as you know you
and I oppose very big a history Buffalo
buffalo yes yes yeah and we very much
enjoyed this thing yes and I learned
something about your Revolutionary War
uh-huh and so you know it's a wonderful
musical Hamilton yeah well it did not
include this real general British Calvin
Snowden and he went stupid people even
had one storm all the German names they
run together you know what I mean snippy
bulimic flop he was he was a famous
German general who helped out the
Americans oh he totally head out have
you seen this thing small wonder that
lady robot from the 80s who helps pick
up all the dirty things from mr.
Belvedere living room I know no one here
knows what you're talking about that was
only in I will tell you what happens it
is now Valley Forge you have just lost
Philadelphia to the Brits its 1777 it's
super cold washing is here people are
eating shoes here comes greatly fear
help from stormy and now imagine it's
like the Dirty Dancing montage you know
hungry eyes is playing Patrick Swayze as
he are making a like a cup out of clay
while Tammy Tammy Lovato is here he
trades not Demi the father anyway he
trained her truth
yes befriend her treat stranger true our
troops did not know how to fight and
thanks Shubin Ivan stineman yes ok I'm
striving John taught us how to fight any
inmate of man I think a military man you
wrote a very wonderful manual he also
said to separate the latrines from the
kitchens like I would you poopoo where
you eat
the song from the offspring had not yet
been written we don't do keep them
separate ok ok 1994 I know that's a
great reference and I if you got it
you're going to get some Turtle Wax
we have a picture of here you as von
Stuben there you are yeah there you are
writing the proclamation that people
should not approve and eat in the same
place absolutely I'm going so deep yes
that this a Napoleon outfit from Amazon
that's fine but I want to tell you when
you go deep into the character you
become like a spelunker in the cold spot
caverns you know looking at stalagmites
and stalactites no exploring that's what
I'm doing ok we're very happy for you
lots of topics recovered in this audio
book like ok what like Elvis right
surface or things like UFO festival the
Kentucky Derby having exactly Derby
Kentucky Derby
I'm sorry Kentucky Kentucky Derby hockey
why we're teeth and it's French diamond
punch button Kentucky Derby yes Kentucky
Derby yeah I've gone there because as a
child my cousin 3 pock told me is that
horses were just criminal unicorns who
had performed some kind of crime in
another galaxy robbery second-degree
murder nobody knows and they are sent to
earth and they had their horns remove oh
and the most villainous of all of these
unicorns must run around in a dirty over
and the most rudest they go to this
place Kentucky Derby it's like the
Rikers Island of unicorns yeah ok
and so I discovered them so anyone who
listens to this is gonna end up being
dumber when it's over
this is a relative term relative :